بعد عشر سنوات من اطلاق روايه حوجه التي
اثارت الكثير من الجدل وحققت تعلم مبيعات
في السعوديه لمده 11 شهرا تم الكشف عن
فيلم يعرض قريبا يحمل نفس اسم الروايه تم
اقتباسه منها ولكن برؤيه مختلفه على يد
المخرج ياسر الياسر المزيد في هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
احنا نقدر نشوفهم بس هم ما يقدروا
تمر 10 سنوات على اصدار روايه حوجا اليسرت
عام 2013 واثاره الكثير من الجدل هذه
الروايه اليوم بمناسبه مرور 10 سنوات
عليها تم تحويلها الى فيلم طوال السنوات
الماضيه كانت يتم التحديث للفيلم لكن لم
يكن احد يعرف اليوم تم الكشف عن الفيلم
اللي راح يطلق في السينمات
واللي يحكي نفس قصه الروايه لكن مع وجود
بعض الاختلافات اللي لا يتوقعها المشاعر
ابوك يحوجا هو جلاله الملك ميعاد ملك ملوك
الجانب الفلاح
نجم الى هذه الانواع من الاعمال ولكن اذا
ضلينا احنا بعقليه بانه الجمهور عاوز كده
فراح نظرح نوقع احنا نسوي كوميدي
فاكيد لازم مش انا بس في اشخاص بقوني وفي
اشخاص معايا
انه يحاولوني يقدمونه الجديد وانا اعتقد
اذا اقدم
لمستوى عقليه المشاهد العربي اعتقد راح
الى قنوات
[تصفيق]
كل واحد يقدر يكون لبابه بين العالمين
هي بنت مره قويه وفي نفس الوقت ناعمه همم
دوره تعلقت فيه كثير صراحه
معكم
وهذا كانت اكثر شيء مخيف بالنسبه لي انه
احنا بنتكلم عن شيء وصل للناس عندها تصور
عن الشخصيه وعن الفيلم همم لكن همم
لنتمنى ولنمل انه بجهد الكاتب ابراهيم
عباس اللي شارك في الفيلم والمخرج استاذ
ياسر الياسري انه مقدم تصور مختلف فريد بس
في نفس الوقت
في احرار هيقف في وجهكم